it's great to be here to talk to you
today you heard all my background and be
happy to talk to that in the Q&A session
as much as you'd like probably one of my
proudest accomplishments though is to
have I have three children and two of
them are actually here in school right
now I don't see them though but would
you please raise our yeah oh there there
nice to see you boys I would have seen
you last night but you were out partying
so I couldn't do that no just kidding
they study all the time it's really an
interesting time to be talking about
leadership you know it's certainly an
unprecedent time I don't think I have to
tell all of you that and in addition to
crisis in our economic situation in the
world today I think we also have a
crisis in leadership and if you think
about how many leaders whether it's in
the business world or other
organizations have fallen you know that
says a lot and I think you know you all
have the opportunity to take a hard look
at that and ask some questions about why
that's going on there was a study
recently that CEO credibility is it at
all-time low and that CEOs are somewhere
between a villain a liar and incompetent
and those are the highlights of the
study so it's you you don't feel really
like people look to you and say oh wow
you're a CEO aren't you a great person
but you know what they're not all the
same and I think we have a lot to
demonstrate that some bad examples are
not the ones we should follow so what
does that mean for all of you I think
more now more than ever they're huge
opportunities for great leadership and
here at Stanford having the opportunity
to have with the peers you have which is
an amazing group just to get into this
school and the best respected professors
and instructors you know what a
wonderful experience to learn a lot and
learn what it means for your own
leadership as you heard about my
background I had a little bit of a you
know different unconventional path when
I got out of school it was a recession
out of undergraduate I had no money and
I just start getting odd jobs and I
worked at the post office sorting mail I
went to college paid my way through and
I'm sorting mail and I said boy what a
great accomplishment I know every ZIP
code in Illinois but it was you know
they paid me that paid paid my bills for
a while but you know what taught me a
lot it taught me a lot about how to
treat people in leadership so as I watch
as I
sorting mail sitting working the
nightshift by the way you learn what
meal do you eat when you get out of
school you notice at breakfast lunch
dinner when do you sleep it really is a
challenging time but it's a boring job a
really boring job and I looked around me
it's a lot of these people are going to
do this for their whole life and how and
what I also learned is it was a boring
job tedious a night seemed like forever
and the people who are leading that or
managing that made it even worse and I
will never forget that saying you know
how do you how do you find a way to
bring dignity and some element of fun if
possible to job that's tedious and for
the rest of my career
you know I'd be managing people that
were in situations like that so I
remember how I felt and I think that was
one of the best lessons I had even
though it wasn't you know a glamorous
job you know it certainly taught me a
lot now I have the opportunity to
opportunity as an opportunity to lead
Sarah Lee which roughly 44 thousand
people were 13 billion dollars on global
sales and you heard some of the brands
what people don't know mostly about
Sarah Lee is that it is such an
international company we do sell in 200
countries where the world's third
largest coffee provider and if you're in
Europe at all you'll see the brand name
Dow Egberts Maison du cafe different
names by different countries and
probably well not probably up to 70% of
our profit comes outside the United
States so if you say Sarah lead anybody
you usually say cheesecake and in
reality that's probably the smallest
part of our company so you know we
recently entered this new era of
presidential leadership and in this
crisis the topics of leadership and
management come up all the time so I'd
like to spend a little bit of time
talking about our own experience and
what we've had to deal with and what
that means means to me and to us and the
company and everybody has a different
definition of leadership and someone
once told me you know the best thing to
find out is if you turn around anybody's
behind you following you you're probably
leading and it's a great opportunity to
set the tone but really a leader is
really someone who inspires people to
act and to do the right thing not just
to get things done and check the box but
to do the right thing and even if it's
unpopular difficult it's something we
all have to do
leaders need to participate it's not
just watching over things a leader
listens leads and learns during the
process and has to make some tough
decisions many times but that leader
also accepts blame for failure and
shares credit for success in essence a
leader leads so I try to be the best
leader I can certainly I'm not perfect
but what I find most challenging about
my job now are the one I'm in is that
it's necessary to make investments for
the long term you have to do that
because you're setting the course for
the future but the pressure on the short
term is just extraordinary you know I
think all of you see it read it about it
but it's you know quarterly earnings
it's this month what's going on it's
next month in the long term is really
what's going to matter if you're gonna
make a sustainable difference so I call
this managing for the long term in a
short term world so we we see our
government dealing with these issues
right now they're trying to figure out
what short-term do we need to do what
stimulus package but also how do we do
it in a way that really affects the
long-term health of our economy and
trying to get that back on track and
this it's a balancing act and that's
what you know I face all the time and
what I and my team have been working on
since I actually got this job about four
years ago one example of this balancing
is creating value for shareholders over
time you know that's that's who I have
to report to and deliver something to
and that's what every CEO has to do but
the question is who are the shareholders
you know is it the day trader is it the
hedge fund manager the short seller is
it a value investor what is it and and
what's over time you know sometimes over
time can be as short as a couple days so
you're really having to figure out which
whose needs are you trying to meet and
so with all these different perspectives
it really takes some courage
and takes leadership to get the board
and the management to really focus on a
long term when those short-term
pressures are in your face every day so
that's what we did starting in 2005 we
embarked on a comprehensive
transformation of Sarah lean and at that
time as Dean mentioned we're a holding
company we had a disparate group of
companies reporting into a central
location but just merely sending their
profits in and that was about it
so they're very independently run and
didn't have a unifying purpose and
things were going okay but we knew if
this was going to be successful for the
long run that model wasn't going to work
so we we announced a lot of changes and
the changes really shook the foundation
of everything that was in the company
but we knew we had to do it to be
competitive over the long term and to
get our cost and get some synergies
across these companies so we worked on
this plan to transform scarily into
world-class consumer products company
and that one that would deliver growth
over time get our margins improved and
deliver reliable results so it was
actually today is the anniversary four
years ago that we announced this and it
was a very very big enough with nothing
had started yet but we said here's the
plan here's working do over the next
five years and it was to change our
focus how we operated how we invested in
our business and really define who we
were and what we wanted to be as a
company so during that time period in
the last four years we sold our spun off
40% of the business so we went from a
twenty billion down to you know today
roughly thirteen billion dollar business
and that included our apparel operations
same buddy no which which one that was
Hanes yes we sold underwear we
implemented a lot of changes in our
infrastructure we created global IT
centralized procurement restructure our
international operations we consolidated
many headquarters into one in outside of
Chicago but that meant moving people
from you know multiple cities to the one
and we worked on developing a new
culture and I really can't emphasize
this enough without a new culture you
couldn't get done what we were trying to
get done and the list goes on and on I
could tell you more about a lot more
changes but I'm actually pleased to be
here today and say you know we've really
made a big evolution where we've gone
from this holding company structure to
one that were we refer to it as an
allied group of companies that focus on
food beverage and household and body
care products around the world
so we centralize those critical
functions that could provide that we can
leverage our scale in and increase our
efficiency it's been a lot of work it's
not it's not been an easy task and we
could have stayed on the status quo but
I know that the status quo would not
have delivered a great company down the
road in fact it probably would be
deteriorating over time so we knew we
had to change what's going on so while
it took a lot in the short term it was
the right thing to do but I remember
when we first announced it the analysts
thought we were out of our minds I
thought I was out of my mind and they
said you can't do all this at once you
know imagine any one of these big change
initiatives in and of itself is pretty
big but we're doing them all at the same
time period because we needed to really
jolt into a new new company so they said
it's too much we don't believe it so our
stock price plummeted the first year and
so it set us back now they didn't
believe we were fully capable because we
didn't have credibility as a company
they watched Sara Lee over the years and
we'd make announcements of things we
would do and they wouldn't get done and
so that was built up over a number of
years and that's what you know why why
would they expect anything different
than that so you know we launched it we
said we'll get it done and after four
years we've reported every step along
the way where are we on this
transformation but through this you know
it really I learned that real change
takes real time but it's if you want
real results you have to do it and you
have to stay committed to it so in this
time period we've grown our core brands
and we're gaining market share in key
geographies and in key categories but
unfortunately right now it's not
reflected in our stock price and that
certainly is very disappointing so the
question is does that mean we should
change what we're doing and look for a
different answer well no we don't think
so because so many things have to be in
place to make a company great and
sometimes these things are hard to get
in place but ultimately the best way to
get a higher stack price is to continue
to grow and improve the business and so
we're really staying focused on that
until we know that it's not the right
answer so we also know that system-wide
capabilities are key to success and that
I can tell you is not something the
analyst community ever asks one question
about or even looks at it or even thinks
about so while you're building these
capabilities you know it's all that is
there are the numbers to watch but we we
know that over time the numbers will
come if we do the right things so but
like like most management teams we do
need to make modifications I'm not
saying we're staying true to every
element of our plan but
in an environment like this you have to
look at things a little differently and
so we need to reduce costs even more and
we need to drive additional sales but we
have to continue at the same time to
create value for the long term so these
things include you know as we look at
the long term first is governance really
which is all about accountability second
is strategy which is all about our focus
and third is about operations which
comes down to execution so let me just
talk a little bit about each of those so
if you start with governance which is
accountability it starts with the board
and it starts with me and as a CEO I
know I'm accountable for Sara Lee's
performance if I don't deliver the
results my job is online that's just the
reality of the thing so to help me drive
success and to keep my job I use the
board's expertise experience and
diversity to make the business better
it's really it's that simple so good
government good governance which you
read a lot about these days it doesn't
just mean regulations and policies which
there are plenty of right now because
even if the same rules and policies are
in place for every single board we would
find some boards effective and some not
so effective so why would that be well I
think it's because even though everybody
has the policies in place and can check
the boxes on that stuff in order to make
the board strong you have to have the
right people working within a right
environment so you know sometimes what
happens in a board was kind of a mystery
to people but if you create the right
environment you could get very good help
and support from the board so as dean
mentioned I've served on many corporate
boards and I can tell you that every
single one of them are different they do
not behave the same so some require you
to do nothing more than show up attend
the meeting listen and leave that's not
a lot of fun and others really can take
advantage of what a board can offer
outside perspective years of business
experience and truly gain the knowledge
of all the members sitting around the
table
so at Sara Lee we believe that talent
management shouldn't just focus on
employees it should encompass the board
as well so we've changed our board as
the company has changed in fact only
five of our 13 current directors
are they are still from the pre
transformation days so one example of
how we've changed
we actually have an activist investor on
our board last year a hedge fund
purchased 7% of our company and in
working with them as one of our share
owners we said you know probably there
are actually smart people they ask the
right questions so we approached their
CEO about being a board member and he
joined a little almost a year ago and
while a lot of companies fight this
situation we embraced it because he we
knew he was gonna have to ask tough
questions he was gonna put push on tough
issues but raised a lot of things that
we should be thinking of and I believe
that our board is much stronger now now
that he is actually joined so we've also
worked hard to create the right
environment for these board members so
as a result of a climate of transparency
and openness and talking about the
business issues they asked the right
tough questions they tackle the tough
issues and they encouraged us to make
the tough decisions and I can tell you
that's a very helpful spot to be in as a
CEO so now that you have the right
people in the right environment working
on the board it's a strategy that guides
us and I'm sure you take a lot of
classes on strategy you really have to
have those strategies in place because
that's what guides the long term
direction and the plans that you know
define the parameters around where we
allocate capital where we have long term
innovation where the priorities for
markets we go into and then you have
limited resources and you have to put
them where you're going to have the most
success so we're now joining you know
starting the next phase of our corporate
journey and we are striving really to uh
perform the market in which we're
competing against and build sustainable
advantage in the marketplace so I'm
convinced that we're going to have a
resulted increased shareholder value as
we execute our plan which brings me to
my next point which is about operations
now many would argue that the most
important component of companies ability
to get to the long term is the ability
to execute and sometimes this is the
least glamorous thing but really I think
probably wanted the most important so
when we started on our transformation we
basically changed how we operated and
the underlying theme we put in place was
continuous improvement because it's a
Bey
now for everything that we do whether
it's continuous improvement in processes
infrastructure our organization or our
product portfolio we worked as a team to
make sure that we had a common goal in
the pursuit of the common goal and then
we all work to improve to prove it as we
go so we knew that we had some long-term
challenges that would need long-term
fixes not not quick ones so solid
execution is really what's helped put us
on the path for renewed prospects for
growth and profit so okay so you've got
good governance you have a clear
strategy hopefully you have a good
execution our continued success though
is going to head hinge on the ability to
recruit and motivate the best people you
know if you have 44,000 people around
the world if they give you all they have
you can get there if they give you half
their energy you're not going to get
there so it starts with a culture you
know are we all operating in common
cultures ours is based on the values of
teamwork integrity imagination
inclusiveness and a passion to excel
when we hire people if they can't pass
the culture test or the values test they
really shouldn't come work for us and as
leaders it's to instill that right
culture and proper values to stand the
test of time this is something that you
have to keep keep at keep that keep at
so we also have a solid mission you know
a lot of times these are posters on the
wall I'm sure you've all worked for
companies where you had a mission vision
values statement think about whether or
not you can remember what it says I
think in a lot of times it's just a
poster but we really wanted to build it
with the input of our employees so we
gave people around the world an
opportunity to input into that so we had
focus groups from Kuala Lumpur to st.
Louis to Chicago to Amsterdam all around
the world and people come in and what is
it what's great about Sara Lee what is
it we're trying to do what strengths
should we retain and how do we connect
it to your own personal job you know is
it connect is it all bring it together
so we did a lot of listening we had
people you know look at all the feedback
and whatnot and really it ended up
writing itself in the end we put it out
on the intranet got comments back on it
and that the simple statement is we want
to be the first choice
of consumers and customers around the
world by bringing together innovative
ideas continuous improvement and people
who make things happen yeah I would
argue that there isn't a person Sarah
Lee that couldn't quote that for you
they know their own personal role they
know the importance of innovation and
they know the importance of making
things better every day so we're still
focused on the same statement and we're
actually happy about that because we
haven't found a reason to change it in
good times that weren't bad so what one
thing we just recently did relates a
little bit to our culture and values we
introduced a program called return ships
and return ships are like internships
really but they're aimed at people
who've taken time away from work either
to take care families or serve in the
military or other reasons so we offer a
chance for people to get back into the
work force in a flexible arrangement as
well as some training and networking
opportunities and we're hoping that
these return ships much like internships
turn into full-time jobs although they
might be flexible full-time jobs and
employment so this this is a tale of
pool of talent that most companies tend
to ignore and if any of you know people
who've been out for a number of years
you can't get interviews you can't even
get interviews so we open the door and
we've gotten more than a thousand
resumes in a very short period of time
and if you google it you'll see they've
been endless articles written about this
program so you know it's it's it's
obviously hit a chord in a need for
people but when the media was
interviewing me on this they'd say why
would you introduce return ships now you
know the economy's bad why are you doing
this and with all that's going on the
financial markets why launch this and my
answer was well why not now you know
when times are hard the need for great
great people doesn't diminish in fact it
grows even stronger so we need good
people to help us get through this and
now it's not the time to abandon plans
or stop searching for great people it's
time to find them and make the plans
work so we've all seen tough situations
before you know I'm a bit older so I've
seen more tough ones but recessions
unemployment the tech bust you know
right in the critical place we are in
the country right now and they make
things harder but they don't make them
impossible and as each of you begin your
post end
careers you're gonna have to deal with
this economy as well you know it's
certainly not over in the next year or
two so there are few things I just want
to share about what have I learned about
managing in difficult times or good ones
what I've learned over the years first
of all this is really revolutionary
thought but the customer pays the bills
there is no money if customers don't buy
what you sell or the service you provide
you have to focus on them always and
give them what they want and do it
better than the competitors do and one
example I just experienced at Sarah
Leah's when I first came to the company
a little almost five years ago I called
on this company Cisco that's sys CEO
nuts he is CEO and it happens to be the
largest food service distributor in the
world they they were enormous and they
had potentially be a huge company but
the first meeting I went to they said
not only do we not do any business with
you no one is allowed to say your name
in the company
we hate Sara Lee the guy told me he said
we hate Sara Lee so the relationship had
been damaged so much that they didn't
want to talk to us so we just kept
chipping away at it kept calling on them
you know like good salespeople do you
know you bounce back up and go back and
try to get them to try something so we
we did and things improved a lot and the
relationship definitely got repaired and
the evidence I have of this is I went
there last week and we were presented an
award for being one of their top 10
suppliers this is out of a list of like
6,000 suppliers they have we're number
six I was like how could that happen I
mean it was incredible so fast to move
up and it was really so gratifying
because the basics of business is about
selling things to customers that they
want to buy and giving them a service
and you don't let up until until they
see that in you so we know we're making
progress the second thing is reduce
reduce reduce in in difficult times it's
even more important to relentlessly
eliminate waste and reduce cost and
these are times and this isn't just
chopping heads off it's finding ways to
do things better and more efficiently so
if you take costs out of the business
ongoing you'll be
really a good company but during this
time period few take even more costs out
you'll come out of the recovery that
much stronger so with our continuous
improvement effort we had a very strong
coat cost focus and a lean mindset
across the company and we've been
successful last four years hundreds of
millions of dollars have come out but
right now it's not enough you know we're
all being challenged with you know
competitive market plays consumers who
are changing their purchasing be a
pattern so you have to be able to get
the value to the consumer even more so
so we launched a project we call Project
accelerate and it's a multi-year project
to provide an additional 200 to 250
million dollars over the next couple of
years and the success of this is going
to be key for us immediately and over
the long term you know to keep our
momentum going
third thing learning for me is allocate
resources wisely and obviously cash is
king all the time but especially now
cash is king with the liquidity
tightening that's going on so we even
we've managed our cash very
conservatively and a couple years ago we
were getting beat up about it saying why
do you have cash why are you sitting on
cash why don't you lever up and you know
take your company you know get the
benefit of higher leverage well as we
look back now we're very happy we didn't
do that and it's helped us weather the
storm but now driving cash is is
absolutely critical and you know you
have to keep revisiting your plans and
making sure that everything you're doing
still makes sense and then forth people
have the answers in tough times and in
good times but tough times especially
you have to rely on your people and the
employees have the answers people are
closest to the business have the answers
before you know layers above them even
begin to see what the answers are
question is can you tap into what they
know and know how to do and help them
help you solve what you need to do in
the company so you know what might one
of my favorite sayings is one that Wayne
Calloway was a former chairman and CEO
of PepsiCo he said you have two ears and
one mouth use them in that proportion so
a lot of times it's you know you have to
communicate communicate communicate
which people people often translate into
tell tell tell talk talk talk but really
the most important thing is to listen
and if you get your people to
participate in solving the problems by
giving you the answers and you listen to
them and you empower them to act you
know half the battle is done so for us
you know you'd listen day to day but we
conducted an engagement survey about six
months ago and first time we ever did it
200 percent of population and and we got
more than 90 percent participation all
the way from bread route driver to
forklift operator to senior management
and what do they think how we doing is
it is it are we following our values are
we empowering people or giving them the
freedom to act and so we have all that
data and it's broken out by geography
and we're now in the process of having
teams work on improvement you know it is
what it is and there's always room for
improvement so why don't we look at our
data and say what can we do differently
to make sure we're getting the most out
of our culture and our people so we're
very excited about that we think that'll
take us to another level so and last to
conclude - good then to go to QA but
leadership really is more important than
ever right now and if leaders bury
themselves in their work which is easy
to do never being seen or heard that's
not gonna help so we've we've gone out
of our way to try to you know get out
there more we had an investor conference
where we had our senior team talked to
all the analysts sharing our results and
we're head as a company talking about
our strategies and plans and then you
know having an interactive session and
it's easy to stand up when everything's
great and give answers but it's harder
when it's tough but people still won't
know what are you doing about it and
where are you going and it's even more
critical as leader of people that you
get out in front of your people and talk
about the business if I if I pulled up
all the articles that were written about
me or our company our employees
certainly would not have there wouldn't
have a lot of confidence because I have
to say it's not on you know glowing
great news so people look to their
leaders to give them the perspective and
how should they be thinking about things
and you know what why should I have
confidence in our leadership team and in
the company so we're all depends on it
and you have to be out in front of them
so I say it's now time for leadership
and like I said when I started out it's
a tremendous opportunity for all of you
you know the there's an economic crisis
can't avoid it looks like there's no end
in sight right now and it's easy to
think that the problems we face are too
big to conquer and that you know people
can't solve them but we can and we will
it's it's going to happen we will always
do it so it's now at I'm ever going to
be part of the solution by remaining
focused on what you can control
sticking to your long-range plans and
avoiding knee-jerk reactions and having
confidence in yourself and your
decisions so as we emerge from this I
think peep there will be people who saw
opportunity and others who saw only
crisis people who saw solutions where
others saw only problems and they'll
come from all levels of the organization
and they're gonna have different titles
different job responsibilities different
ages different genders but they'll have
one thing in common they will be our new
leaders so I hope that many of those
people are actually sitting here in that
audience and take us to new heights
so with that I'd be more than happy to
take any questions you have
thank you okay anything's fair game way
back there so you've talked a little bit
about how you balance the pressures
coming from analysts versus the needs of
the company you've also been personally
scrutinized and held up as an example of
the woman who can have it all
the family that high-powered career can
you talk about how you balance the
pressures of other people wanting to use
you as a role model the media wanting to
hold you up as this example versus what
you need in your own personal and
professional life yeah so it's a great
question when I when I first met PepsiCo
I think I was doing well at the company
and I you know I think I had a great
future and I love my job I love my job
but I wanted to spend some more time at
home so my way of dealing with that you
know that issue was I left my job now I
don't recommend that for everyone but
that is an option but when I left my job
I became I said my moment of Fame and
life was for quitting my job that's not
exactly what I always aspired to have
happen headlines you know quits her job
I was on every talk show etc so I was
the poster child for a woman chucking it
all and leaving her job so there was a
lot of pressure that came with that and
I said you know I really struck me as
I'm one person making a personal choice
that's right for me I don't claim as a
right choice for anyone else but I think
in the end that's what every person has
to do male or female you have to say in
life here's the list of things that are
important to me and what my goals and
aspirations are and here's what I have
to give up and trade off to get them or
modify them but it's only the right
decision for you
so I finally got I got comfortable with
that saying this is my choice my
decision I'm very happy I made it you
know if I had to go back I'd do it a
hundred times over but there is pressure
with that and so when I came back to
work it went in Reverse ah you can come
back to work you can come back to work
so while I never wanted to be that you
know poster child or that role model or
whatever I figured I have a little bit
of a responsibility now and so what I
try to do is tell people you can't have
it's impossible they're only seven days
a week 24 hours a day only you can
decide what you want what's the most
important what you keep what you give up
and then I did this thing this return
ship program you know I really drove it
because what I found is people who did
leave the work made the choice to leave
the workforce for family reasons most
mostly women they couldn't get back in
and here there were lawyers and vestment
bankers you know people with tons of
experience and they didn't lose their
brains they were instead running society
so if you go all across the country you
know women are running society wasn't
making the schools better making
everything work better so I said but
they they can't get back in the door and
they can't they don't have the
confidence in themselves anymore so
we're trying this in our own little way
I hope every company steals the idea and
finds this new pull of town to get back
so it's not easy but I now feel that I
at least have a role to play to make it
seem that you can you can make it work
over time oh hi Brenda hey Alex so from
the time you took off to spend with your
family I was wondering how you
translated the lessons managing a
successful household to managing a
successful American icon well thank you
Alex
I found the challenge is that's fairly
much easier I know it's uh look at the
products I turned out in my household
you know I feel pretty good about that
my proudest moment are my children it's
different you know it's a little
different now to doing what I'm doing
because all I've three children they're
all at college and I go to work I work I
remember when I worked and my children
are at home you always feel that
pressure about wanting to be with your
kids and that's where you feel pressure
now I actually feel less pressure
because I know even if I came home my
kids wouldn't be there so for me the
timing of highway sequences actually
helped because you know I could work
around the clock and nobody would miss
me it is a balancing act oh that's what
it is
you have to juggle it make it work yes
you mentioned that you maintained a
conservative balance sheet and that has
obviously been pretty important for
companies right now you talked about was
that a personal philosophy or how did
you fight that urge to take on a lot of
debt and kind of that decision-making
process we this is a little bit to of
managing for the long term so we knew
that we're going to have to stay the
course both from a strategy standpoint
but we also had to have our balance
sheet and their financial approach
support what we knew we were going to
have to deal with all the time and we
had to build in some risk factors we
were launching on things that you know
we're quite drastic for a company not
drastic but big and we said well if this
goes wrong this goes wrong this goes
wrong you know that leverage it it's a
slim margin that you have to make you
know have cover issues cover problems so
that that's why we did it it was against
our strategy at the time protecting us
on the downside till we knew for sure
that this plan was taking hold and
actually the board was very supportive
of that so while the returns you know on
the stack could have been driven higher
if we had higher leverage we said what
if something slips you know we don't
want to be walking walking on that brink
of you know being a liquid so it was
really against our plan that we built
the capital structure and we looked at
it over time in modifies so we went in
to share buyback program over time and
did some other things but it was
balancing the capital structure to allow
us to achieve what we're trying to do
yeah culture is the hardest thing how do
you change the culture is that fair
culture is the hardest thing to change
human beings resist change no matter
what you get used to a certain way so
changing a culture takes multiple years
and things that support it so the things
we did to try to support it is ok you
get a common mission vision values so
that's an important first step probably
one of the most important thing that
triggers a signal for you're serious
about the culture
who you hire you fire so we put in a
place a very extensive talent review
process and who you promoted sent said
more to the organization than anything
you could have said in words and people
that you got rid of you know maybe we're
delivering the results but didn't fit
with helping the culture move so that's
that travels you know those kinds of
things travel so it was our talent
review process
it was our compensation process because
part of our culture we wanted to build
accountability at a higher level so we
had a very high leverage you know a
overperform you get lot more money you
don't perform you don't get money and it
was a company in the past that had a
very narrow band you know if you got a
bonus it was ranging from you know 98%
to 105 percent you know well you don't
differentiate performance in that regard
so he said know you're accountable and
if you deliver the results which is what
we needed you'll get paid more training
some training but mostly not formal
training more on-the-job and then really
one of the biggest things was
implementing lean you know if you know
lean it's all about having a process
discipline and having people who do the
work find a way to take eliminate waste
out of the system so we engaged
employees via training on lean so we
started out by doing it in some plants
show that it worked moved to more plants
more plants and we took it outside the
manufacturing location and if a leader
if a manager knows how to use lean it's
all about tapping into the town of
people who do the work to problem-solve
and do all that kind of thing so that
was a big cultural mindset and then
innovation is another way you know it's
we said innovations core to our mission
statement so we built in a very strong
disciplined approach to innovation
trying to free people up as opposed to
staying you know near in to take chance
and to you know gamble on things against
clear consumer needs though you know
there was process discipline to it so as
a combination of all these things coming
together and so we're slowly moving I
think this engagement server is our next
step to really get it down to each local
level you know some of our divisions are
way ahead and some little workgroups are
way behind and so if we can target where
we need more improvement we can work
more focused on it
yes so I'm wondering did you ever doubt
your ability to be able to get the job
done and or how you deal with critics
who may have doubted your ability to get
back into the role everybody hear that
okay um okay I'll just say what's on my
mind I'm I'm my worst critic
I'm my own worst critic and fear is a
great motivator so I always say
everything I do wrong and I don't like
to fail and I don't like to fail other
people so I yes I've had I've had my own
doubts I've had my own my own self
criticism but but you have to but that
motivates me more just personally what
motivates me more so there comes a point
where all the critics I mean I was
blasted I mean if I was blasted in the
press I mean really blasted and I'm one
of my first presentations to the analyst
community guy stood and said why do you
think after spending seven times taking
care of kids seven years taking care of
kids that you can do this job you know
well so you know I gave an answer it
stayed calm I didn't you know throw
anything at him or anything like that
although I felt like it the criticisms
everywhere and I learned I've learned
over time I have to have a thick skin to
that because if you really let it get to
you it gets in the way and there's just
too much to be done do I like it of
course not you don't like it so but in
you know I've said to my own team I go
you know we should use this as a way to
say it will show them that's all of it I
don't we'll show them you can criticize
us now but you know when the numbers are
there and their stock price is up I
don't think I'll be hearing from you
anymore so but it's hard you know it's
you're you're very visible and I think
you know as a female I'm a little bit
more visible you know I think I get more
scrutiny waiting for me to fail so they
can be write an article about it yes so
wondering when you when you put your
emphasis on the long term thinking the
next five or ten years what sort of big
themes to use
facing Sara Lee and how do you go about
the process of identifying them
prioritize that yeah well I'd say for
sure health and wellness is a big thing
and we're a food company so if we don't
address that we will not have products
that are relevant to what a big big
consumer and growing need is they have
to taste good but health and wellness
it's going to be regulated you know but
there's an underlying current that the
consumers in fact are looking for more
of those options and you know we have to
do something about the obesity challenge
in the country in the world really so
that that theme sets direction for us on
product development and so how do we
deal with it we make sure that our R&D
pipeline is working on things that
deliver against that consumer need and
it might be working with grain suppliers
for you know a more nutritional grain
and our bread like we've done or you
know taste profiles that can be
delivered without as many calories or
sweeteners substitutes that sort of
thing that that's definitely a big trend
that's from a business standpoint you
know you have to keep looking you have
to keep renewing your long-range plan
even though I said you have to have your
plan it has to be renewed because things
change so fast
a theme of customer consolidation that's
been going on for a long time so that's
that's really what led us to do this
transformation because here you have a
customer like just take Walmart we had
five or six meat companies calling on
Walmart one competing with each other
one hottub group with another hot dog
group calling on the customer believe me
the customer did not like that so we
said you know it's it's our issue we
have to bring it together have one voice
to the customer so there's a theme of
the customer and private label and the
role that that's going to play in the
food category and figure out how do we
get value with innovation and a customer
coverage and joint planning effort that
deals with these big not only
international companies but
international companies
I've gone about me
or some career decisions touch on those
and if you want to talk about some
business ones who can do that but I I
was I grew up my first big decision was
to go to frito-lay I was working in
Chicago Wilson Sporting Goods you know
before that I sorted mail and was a
waitress then I got a job I remember my
first job paid $10,000 a year and I was
working in distribution for Wilson and
then I got into marketing so I said well
if I'm gonna be a marketer then I've got
to get with the big-time marketer so I
got the opportunity transferred
frito-lay so that that was a major
pivotal point because it set me on a
whole different course so that was one
big move and I had to move to Dallas
another personal a professional decision
was I was in the marketing department at
Pepsi I was the head of Pepsi brand when
Coke reformulated you're all probably
too young to even remember that it was a
big deal and so I was at marketing it
was great you know I had a great
reputation for Pepsi marketing people
and all that kind of stuff and then I I
was asked to move into a sales job and
it was actually a lower level job and it
was in the Northeast and was the head of
sales for our on-premise division which
was its you know taking syrup to
fountain accounts you know to put in I
said a lower level how could you do that
to me I'm good yeah I shouldn't get you
know a lower level job and sales you
know going from having MBA marketers
working for me to having Teamsters you
know driving route trucks and unionized
and tough tough nuts and you know all
that stuff best move I ever made to you
know another great move because it you
know if you're gonna be a general
manager and know how things work you
have to be able to you know lead people
that don't work in the same building as
you they'd have different aspirations so
those Teamsters to me were like working
at the post office
that's what they're gonna do for their
life now how did they come to trust me
as a leader you know so that so that was
a big personal move and then you know
another big one that was pivotal for my
learning process was I was having my
third child there is
that little tot and I said and I had my
mother was very ill and so I said I have
to take time off want to have a baby and
to see my mother and so I said that may
mean I lose my job and maybe they don't
take me back so but I said it was worth
it was worth for the right reasons I did
it so I left and when I came back I
didn't have there wasn't a role that
same role was gone and but Pepsi let me
come back to work they just didn't have
this same job for me so the person at
the time who I and it was the CEO of the
beverage group he gave me a job of all
this stuff you know do this and this and
this and this and so I called myself
miscellaneous because there was no job
was just a bunch of stuff but that
miscellaneous job turned into creating a
transformation at Pepsi moving if you
could read about it but it was talking
it's called the right-side up company
turning the whole focus to you know to
management to the customer all the
things that went with it
and that taught me so much about
changing a culture or massive change in
an organization and I've leaned heavily
on that as I've gone to Sarah Lee so
there's three three career points and
you have to take a little risk with your
career you know and it may not seem
right at the time but if you can always
say hey I'm gonna learn a lot more in
this next role you ought to do it if you
keep doing the same thing you'll be
great at it but you'll not broaden
yourself to be able to take on the
bigger jobs okay
I'd say I wasn't as prepared as I needed
to be to deal with the external analyst
investor community you know when in in
the role I'm at in I have to be that
spokesperson and I don't I don't think I
was as prepared as I needed to be I
didn't realize what it would be like as
much you know I hadn't dealt with them
before but it wasn't I wasn't the person
on the point so if I had to do it over
again I think I might talk to more
people get lessons learned from other
people other CEOs talk more about that
get advice in terms of how do you how do
you deal with them tell the story you
know because because I made a big
mistake well need to first announce a
transformation made a huge mistake and I
linked it to this thing I'm telling you
about we laid out the plan the five-year
plan
from a company that didn't have a lot of
credibility and we said by fiscal year
twelve our fiscal year twelve we would
hit a twelve percent margin so that's
all we were being measured against
during the time period and when we
wouldn't have that trajectory as fast as
it did or we slipped terrible there
everyone hit the twelve percent margin
we told you you'd never do it I never
should have given him a number it was
too far out it was too precise there was
too much distance to travel without
knowing the ups and downs of what we
were gonna face so that was a mistake
and may someone probably would have told
me don't be that precise but I didn't
know that so we've been recovering from
that you know so we finally said forget
the 12% we're just gonna make progress
we'll tell you when we get there
and the whole question of guidance to
the external world is a is a big subject
you know you probably can't people are
moving away from giving as much because
you get slaughtered by your own your own
direction CEO how do you balance
managing and leading so just the details
first what Peter Drucker said management
is doing things right and leadership is
doing the right things right to to
difference you have to do both or you
have to have people to support you doing
both so I think more the burden on me is
leadership because you have to bring the
whole organization along with you and
you have to make sure that you're
setting clarity of where you're going so
everybody knows and you have to inspire
people to you know step up that it's
worth challenge now at the same time we
have tasks to do and so my my managerial
part of it is clarity of who's doing
what what the timetable is using my
meetings to track progress against it
having scorecards on key metrics you
know using process discipline to make
sure it's in place how do I know it's in
place I got a Turk metrics so it's
really really the balance of it so you
can't get away from doing both all right
then last question thank you all very
much good luck sorry